puedes analizaron 52 casos de personas
fallecidas o heridas qué conclusiones
extraen
Rosa lo que hemos encontrado en esta
investigación que se enfoca en el uso
desproporcional de la fuerza en el uso
letal de la fuerza por parte de los
cuerpos de seguridad tanto policiales
como militares es que en Perú se han
cometido ejecuciones extrajudiciales con
la intención de castigar a las personas
que salían a protestar que tomaban las
calles particularmente comunidades
históricamente marginalizadas de pueblos
indígenas y campesinos por lo que
nuestra evidencia demuestra que hubo un
sesgo racista para atacar de manera
generalizada a estas personas inclusive
se han asesinado a jóvenes que ni
siquiera participaban en las protestas
que se habían acercado por curiosidad o
que simplemente eran transeúntes
cercanos a una manifestación
precisamente porque los cuerpos de
seguridad militares y policiales
hicieron ese uso excesivo de la fuerza
un uso letal de la fuerza en la que se
utilizó armas de guerra como
rifles de alto alcance rifles Gali entre
otros que están prohibidos bajo las
normas internacionales para el control
de protestas y Erika en base a sus
hallazgos ustedes indican que se trató
de una estrategia organizada del estado
o de casos aislados
Rosa claramente dado los patrones las
repeticiones el uso de las fuerzas
letales en diferentes o localidades del
país nos demuestra que hubo una
intención de castigo organizada y Por
ende hemos pedido a la fiscal de la
nación que investigue no solo a los
perpetradores directos es decir a
quienes jalaron el gatillo sino que
también a las altas autoridades que a
pesar de saber que se estaban cometiendo
esas violaciones a los Derechos Humanos
no hicieron nada para prevenirlos o que
quizás ordenaron el ataque Y ustedes
señalan que existe riesgo de impunidad
por qué
bueno hemos estado documentando en las
últimas semanas
algunas alertas de preocupación frente a
retrasos y omisiones en las
investigaciones realizadas por la
fiscalía nacional la fiscal nacional ha
creado un cuerpo especial un equipo
especial de diez personas Fiscales para
la investigación exclusiva que han
atraído todas las carpetas de
investigación a Lima pero hemos
escuchado de las víctimas en ayacucho en
andahuaylas el temor que tienen de no
tener cercanía ni participación en los
procesos de investigación la lejanía que
tendrán los fiscales de las regiones en
donde se cometieron estas violaciones a
los derechos humanos y la propia fiscal
ha reconocido la carencia de recursos e
inclusive de experticia por ejemplo
experticia balística para poder realizar
las investigaciones Y hasta qué punto
consideran que la investigación llegará
puede llegar hasta Dina boluarte que ha
sido citada a declarar
bueno rosa es importante mencionar que
estas violaciones a los derechos humanos
en el contexto de protestas también se
dan en el marco de un estado de
emergencia en la cual la presidenta
boluarte ASUME toda El Comando verdad
tanto de las operaciones policiales como
de las operaciones militares además bajo
la constitución del Perú la presidenta
es la jefa máxima de las fuerzas
militares Por lo cual hay una
responsabilidad directa tanto por
omisión o por orden de las atrocidades
cometidas por las fuerzas de seguridad